well three's one in Maryland hey Juan
how are you I'll be on David's an honor
honor to speak to you sir how can I help
so I think this is a career question
actually specifically beginning my
career I'm in a good problem my hands
deciding between two interesting offers
essentially narrowed down between a
high-risk high-reward
career offer working for an entrepreneur
whom I've known for a few years and runs
a few businesses and he wants me to help
him expand and see new businesses and he
believes I'm someone who's dedicated and
will work with him and he's had trouble
finding the right people and he's going
to put me on tour under his wing that
just came up last week and I've had an
offer to work for a big company stable
company at a great salary and honestly
was you know they'll offer the perfect
offer and now it's made me doubt because
the offer worked for the entrepreneur
aligns more with my long-term goals of
being a business owner myself the offer
from working for this company is not
specifically entrepreneur does the
company offering you money was they
offered me 85,000 starting salary plus a
ten thousand dollar signing bonus great
so are you just graduate from college I
graduate in May okay and in what field
it is in financial services but I'll be
doing some data analytics for the
company good for you
Wow data analytics coming out of
undergrad undergrad that's right coming
out of underground bank in 85
so wheat good for you yeah the company's
gonna train me they're gonna train me so
that that's attractive as well to me
about that offer very attractive so what
should a entrepreneur or high risk guy
gonna pay you so yeah part of them so a
little background with him he was my
wrestling coach back in high school and
had to leave this game to run his
businesses and he's been doing very well
and what he said in me was hey I I know
you work hard but any motivate you don't
work hard so I'm not gonna pay you as
much as the he knows about the other
offers I have he wants me to have skin
in the game so he he's offered me you
know I'm sure I could negotiate with
them but between 30 and 40 thousand he
wants me to be hungry and get after it
so that's a
yeah let's our consideration is all with
him have you have you noticed that that
no one stayed with him he doesn't have
anybody and that's why he needs help so
that's a good point
I know why because he keeps all the
freaking money that's why if it was 65
or 70 with increases based on your
bringing value to the guy and showing
that you're bringing in more than you
cost fine he's just looking for slave
labor I'll pass list it so I think
that's an interesting point I thought
you have to think about I do think he
has some partners working for him
he's somebody I've known for a while you
know I'm sure in the business world
especially entrepreneurship the others
yeah he's also known you for a while
and he also knows you're worth $85,000
in the open market we've proven that and
so it would be valuable for you to go to
work for a guy that has an
entrepreneurial thing rather than the
big company but the it's not worth fifty
thousand dollars a year and that's what
you're paying for this opportunity but
you're writing him a check for 50 grand
right all right there you oh let me ask
you though so we were just in the
beginning of the conversation last week
at least wanted to get more information
about you know what it would imply of me
working for him if I do meet with him
again
what things do I need to get you know on
paper or just clear to myself things
that you would tell maybe your you know
your son what would you ask yourself
what what how big a check would you
write him to get to work for him mm-hmm
how big a check would you write him
because I'm gonna tell you don't take
the job now okay I would not write him a
check for 50,000 side and he can show
you where the upside is financially to
you other than you just being mentored
by him which I'm not sure he has
anything to give you because he's never
really grown
leaders if he had a room full of the
other leaders that he had grown that
were loyal to him because he was such a
good world-class leader himself than
fine but he can't keep people as what
you told me and I think we figured out
why so if you you know I'm gonna get in
writing exactly what has to take place
in order for me to be winning and in
order for me to get raises and in order
for me to participate in the profits and
if I like all of that I might take 65 or
70 and give this a run that's it